Welcome back everyone
Maximum effort!
There's a brand new video from Deadpool 3
of them trying to kill each other
in the void from Loki
So I'll explain what's going on here
because they're paying off a huge
a huge fan theory
that we've had for a long time.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They still have about two months
of filming left.
They just had to pause
because of the actors strike.
So I'll explain how that's going to affect
what's going on.
but in the video you see Wolverine trying
to kill Deadpool after they get pruned
and sent to the void planet
at the end of time from the Loki series.
So this also does connect a little bit
with what's happening in Loki Season two.
we already knew a bunch of the TVA
characters
were going to be featured in the movie,
but we weren't exactly sure
how that was going to work out.
we had a pretty good idea for how
that was going to happen, but not exactly.
Now we just have a lot more details.
during the fight.
They have a bunch of jokes
about how each of them
have healing factors
so they can heal the damage
really quickly in the fight
just keeps going on and on as they
slowly tire each other out
because they're just healing so fast.
they recreate a couple iconic panels
of Deadpool versus Wolverine
fights in the comics
with him lifting Deadpool up in the air,
impaling him on his claws, and here.
Do they really pay off a super deep cut
fan theory that we've had for a long time?
They eventually start fighting
in the wreckage of the 20th Century
Fox movie studio logo.
Now, remember,
this is happening in the void from Loki,
meaning that the actual Fox logo
got pruned at some point.
It's not clear
if they got pruned from the same moment,
like if Wolverine and Deadpool
were fighting
in the universe around the Fox logo
in, then everybody got pruned.
that.
Because the fox logo looks so old
and broken it seems like that got pruned
at some other point either actually
paying off the meta joke of Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe, but it's Deadpool
kills the Fox Marvel universe
because they're kind of doing that
metaphor early and literally in the movie
metaphorically, it's sort of a swan song
for the Fox Marvel characters
because Disney bought out Fox.
but because this ties in with Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty all the incursions
different universes being destroyed
colliding with each other end
they're incorporating the TBA with
the idea of pruning alternate universes.
they're also effectively
killing off the Fox Marvel universe.
Within the larger MCU continuity,
Deadpool winds up doing something so crazy
he gets the entire Fox Marvel universe
pruned In real life
though the actual Fox studio
still exists after Disney bought Fox.
But it's like a shadow of its former self.
But. A lot of you
will recognize this 20th century Fox logo.
They played it across all the Fox movies
just in general.
Not just Fox Marvel movies, but
all Fox movies like you saw these logos
in front of the original Star Wars trilogy
because Fox released those movies.
it's not clear if this fight is happening.
Later in the movie, after Deadpool
and Wolverine cause a Nexus event so big
in that alternate Fox Marvel universe
that they travel to the TVA proves it.
Or if this fight is happening.
Earlier in the movie
But at some point during this fight, it
looks like they just tire each other out
because the fight goes on for so long
that eventually Wolverine kills out
and they start working together
to figure out how to escape the void
the same way that Loki and Sylvie
did during Loki season one.
Because part of the joke here is
that Deadpool would love Wolverine.
Wolverine would hate Deadpool.
that's why when they release
that original teaser of the two of them
talking about the movie
just in general like hey,
we're going to be doing a Deadpool
and Wolverine movie.
Finally, The logo had Wolverine swiping
his claws through the Deadpool symbol
because at least at first,
Wolverine will try to kill Deadpool
like it'll be Deadpool versus Wolverine.
Then eventually they will work together.
Now we're all wondering which other
variants they encounter in the void
because they're supposed to be a bunch of
variants of all the Fox Marvel characters
just in general, like the X-Men, Fantastic
Four actors coming back.
We know Ben Affleck's
daredevil is coming back.
We know Jennifer Garner's
Elektra is also coming back
from that universe to Chris
Evans is also supposed
to be coming back in the movie
as his version of Johnny Storm as well.
but on top of that,
there's supposed to be multiple Deadpool
variants
and multiple Wolverine's in the movie.
they might have a joke like the Loki
series, where Loki encountered
a bunch of weirder versions of himself
in the void like Alligator Loki.
Imagine alligator, Deadpool
or Alligator Wolverine,
a wolverine that's just like a regular
looking Wolverine animal.
there was even a report
that they were going
to feature galactic pool
from the Deadpool corps in the movie.
Maybe they see the dead helmet of galactic
pool just lying around in the void,
in the wreckage of everything
that's been proved
there were a ton of Easter eggs like that
during the Loki series,
like the giant pyramids
from the Rama version of Kang.
build the statue of the Living Tribunal,
the Yellowjacket helmet from Ant-Man,
the Avengers Tower, from the reality
where Kang had taken over
and turned it into the Qeng Industries.
that was actually the Mr.
Griffin version of Kang
who's supposed to be featured
at some point during Loki Season two.
But Deadpool three is meant to take place
after the events of Loki Season two.
the Loki season
two episodes are coming in October,
so we'll get a trailer
for that pretty soon.
We already know that Mobius Miss Minutes.
Some of the TVA will be
a big part of Deadpool three,
but they're also introducing a couple of
new TVA characters during Deadpool three.
Matthew McFayden from Succession
is playing a TVA agent named Paradox,
who Mobius assigns
to Deadpool in Wolverine's case
and just tasks him with dealing with them
through the movie.
Emma Corrin is playing a TVA judge
who sentences Deadpool.
Miss Minutes
will probably just be around the TVA.
Snarking with Deadpool.
But. For example,
if you look at their fight here
as it goes
on, they're crashing through the Fox logo.
You notice Wolverine
picking up the severed pieces of Deadpool
Loki literally picks up Deadpool's arm
and throws it at Deadpool so hard that he
crashes through the back of the Fox logo
this is going to be so crazy and so meta.
I love it.
literally and metaphorically
killing the Fox Marvel universe
Pretty much everybody been
joking about this for years.
Like, wouldn't it be awesome
if they did a Deadpool movie?
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe,
but they'll never do something like that.
Is too crazy touch a few years later
and Ryan Reynolds is like,
Oh yeah, we're doing it.
We're totally doing it
now we know why they released the official
HD Shiny Copy that Wolverine first
look earlier this year of him
in the yellow suit from the comics.
It's because that we're going
to be filming all these scenes outdoors
and everybody got videos
of the entire fight scene.
they have about two months of filming
left on the movie, which is a lot.
And they pause because the actors strike.
They just started. So
eventually they will just pick up again.
Reportedly before they had to stop.
They also filmed a bunch of indoor scenes
inside the TVA,
probably right before they get pruned
and sent to the void here.
My guess is that just based on
what happened during the Loki series,
when all beings typically get pruned,
they're given the choice to either
become TB agents because all the TB agents
are variants themselves.
that wound up having to Loki
during Loki season one, like he chose
to become a tbia agent
or they get pruned outright.
Like you can become an agent
or will prune you
Deadpool Wolverine probably do something
so crazy inside the TBA
when they get arrested
that they get pruned on the spot like they
break out into a fight inside the TVA.
lot of people also asking why they gave
Wolverine sleeves in his yellow suit.
Because normally in the comics,
most of the versions of his suits
don't have sleeves.
This is actually a change they did
because of what happened in real life.
So in real life,
Hugh Jackman just had a skin cancer scare,
so they altered his suit
to give him sleeves so as much of his skin
could be covered while they were filming
outdoors as possible, just for protection.
maybe at some point
the sleeves will get ripped off.
So he'll be more comic book accurate.
The suit does look similar to the one
from X-Men, the Animated series.
But like if you look at the hands
here, like the details, it's actually
based on the one from astonishing X-Men.
the other.
Minor change here, too,
is if you look at a lot of the Fox
Marvel movies, Wolverine's claws came from
between his knuckles
and these are more like the comics
where they come from on top of his hands.
The helmet might wind up either
being a cowl
that's just attached to the suit,
or he might just lose the helmet
earlier in their fight.
Or it could just wind up being CG.
Like a lot of the Iron Man, visual effects
There will be a helmet at some point
during the movie.
the main version of Wolverine here in
the movie is meant to be
from the main house of M Universe
that Deadpool travels to in the movie,
but they're supposed to visit the main
X-Men universe,
one of the original movies
at some point too,
because that is the original universe
that Deadpool is from.
it's the same universe
from the first class movies
and at least the original Fantastic
Four movies in the Ben Affleck
Daredevil movie, the electro movie two.
I don't think the newer 2015 Fantastic
Four movie was in that universe,
but that's part of the joke of Deadpool.
Like Fox never really cared much
about their continuity in movies
with the reboots
only loosely trying to explain it.
That's
why Deadpool joked about it so much.
The theory is right now
they're paying off the A38 Universe story
in the ending of Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness, So it's possible
that a lot of the X-Men that are coming
back in the movie are the more comic book
versions from that universe.
So it makes sense if they're going
to visit that universe again.
And we see some of the other X-Men
coming back, baby wearing more colorful
comic book based uniforms, too.
In that universe.
but the entire movie
might not take place in the 838 universe
just because Deadpool is hopping around
with cable's time travel device,
which they also confirm that cable
is not coming back for them to be.
Josh Brolin's cable
will not be in the movie, but his time
travel device will be a big part
of how the movie plays out.
but here's the thing
with the familiar face
that might wind up
being the main villain of the movie.
If the movie goes to a universe
that's meant to be based on the house of M
from the comics a lot of the people
reporting all these cameos, scenes
that they've
since confirmed are also saying
the quote unquote mummy is coming back.
And I think the mummy
they're referencing is Elizabeth Olsen.
Just because of all the Real-Life Memes.
end, either
she winds up being the main villain,
or if we're talking about a familiar face
being the main villain
and they're bringing back
all these old X-Men Fantastic Four actors.
Maybe that familiar face
is a version of Magneto cannot wait
to see what all the other X-Men actually
do look like full on in their costumes.
So just post all your reactions.
I'm so happy that they're finally
giving us Wolverine in a comic book.
Accurate yellow costume.
In related news,
James Gunn just announced a giant portion
of the new version of the Justice League
who will appear in Superman Legacy.
Like a bunch of those characters
will already exist
when Superman Legacy happens.
I'll do a video for that next.
My Mole Secret Invasion episode by video
will post next week after they release it,
so be sure to enable alerts on my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for all my Deadpool 3
videos and click here for that
secret invasion Episode 5 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!